not a bird not a plane and not quite a
recognizable super suit but it turns out
there was a method to The Madness of
Nicholas Cage's aborted Superman lives
costume following the incredible success
of director Tim Burton's Batman
adaptations he set his sights on another
DC hero Superman yeah Spartan planned on
bringing the Man of Steel to the movies
in the 1990s with none other than
Nicholas Cage and the lead role the
feature titled Superman lives was
ultimately scrapped but some production
materials made it out into the public
eye including pictures of Cage's
costumes while he would have worn a more
traditional red and blue Superman suit
the Man of Steel would also sport a
silvery metallic look as well his ontake
on the classic Superman outfit wasn't
designed solely to stand out from the
Past movie versions it actually served a
purpose in the story Superman lives
would have seen Brainiac not only defeat
Superman but kill him though he wouldn't
stay down for long the glitzy outfit
dubbed the eradicator's suit would
resurrect the son of Krypton after his
untimely passing with the help of this
new suit Superman would have regained
his full strength then naturally it
would have offered him an added layer of
protection however the most interesting
part of the suit is how it had the
ability to take on its own humanoid form
it's definitely not the typical Superman
suit and there was a very good reason
for that although it didn't come from
Burton or the screenwriters in a deep
dive into the Nicholas Cage film's
ill-fated production BBC explained how
producer John Peters made it explicitly
clear to co-writer Kevin Smith that
Superman couldn't wear his traditional
blue and red suit while Superman lives
would have featured the iconic and
classic suit there's even a photo of
cage trying it on it's obvious that
Peters was pushing to make this version
of Superman as unique looking as
possible
cool costume thanks my mom made it for
me
either way his vision wouldn't come to
fruition Superman lives was given the
boot by Warner Brothers one reason given
the film was too expensive at least
according to co-screenwriter Dan Gilroy
who told collider that the film was
weeks away from shooting a number of
costume designers and technicians were
already hard at work bringing the film's
script to life it certainly would have
been interesting for audiences at the
time to see Cal L wear a new suit
especially one that's far more
technologically advanced than his
traditional outfit of course these ideas
aren't completely unique to Superman
lives the legendary DC Hero has famously
worn a version of the suits in the
comics and long time readers are well
acquainted with Eradicator by now in The
Death of Superman comic story The Title
Character returned to the pages of DC
Comics after being killed after his
resurrection he sported an entirely new
look with a grown out mullet and a black
and silver suit this outfit absorbs
solar energy to help him recover his
superhuman abilities in the years since
he first wore it on the pages of 1993's
Action Comics number 689 the recovery
suit or as it's often appropriately
called solar suits as appeared multiple
times in a variety of Superman media as
for The Eradicator he's an ancient
Kryptonian weapon comprised of pure
energy and his one sole purpose is to
preserve Kryptonian culture and Heritage
by any means necessary using a body
created in kalel's image he battled and
joined forces with the likes of Steel
Superboy and Cyborg Superman before the
real Superman returned Eradicator then
merged with Dr David Connor after
seemingly dying at the hands of Cyborg
Superman with a second Eradicator
debuting after DC's New 52 relaunch all
in all Tim Burton's Superman lives may
seem a bit strange but ironically it
seems like it was pretty faithful to the
source material
foreign